bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj oggi sono su un
videogame della madonna mentre si chiama
hreik ragazza e l'hanno consigliato un
po di persone la prima inter bisogna
cercare di catturare questo raich che
sarebbe questa presenza strana e capire
se soltanto una leggenda oppure se è
vero che esiste perché esiste dunque
cominciamo ragazzi è una roba che
secondo me è abbastanza [ __ ] perché devo
veramente investigare scoprire se sta
roba è vera è una cosa veramente
fighissima ci siamo già che figo ci
siamo ragazzi questo è mio campo base
puoi saltare questo giorno non notiamo
negli stati uniti ecco questo sarebbe il
rake devo vedere se è vero se soltanto
una leggenda ok allora è stato avvistato
no perché devo avvistarlo io che bello
lo voglio come animale domestico piace
un casino ragazzi ste cose tipo misteri
ma possa riguardare le riprese che ho
fatto fantastico nuova ben affidata da
questo fucile fatemi uscire ragazzi open
door perfetto oh che bello a sono in un
camper fantasia questa è la mia bello la
mia il mio campo base fantasy mila
ragazzi non lo sa nessuno ma sono
eisenberg e cucino metanfetamina nei
boschi abbiamo tutto ragazzi voglio
vedere se riesco a trovare quel bastardo
se riesco
tanti mi piace o mi stato
oh cazzo era non è successo un cazzo
casi mi metto a fare birdwatching e un
cane e un cane ma che cazzo è un tapiro
cos'è sta roba lì c'è striscia la
notizia che non distribuisce la gente un
tapiro vero io sono fa vj che cazzo
scarpi bastardo che si chiama racchetta
da tennis la usi per giocare a tennis
guarda si gioca così attenti cusano
sbagliato che figo rosso piazzale in
giro le videocamere fantastico
piazzavano in giro così a me non si
passa lo stronzo lo vedo anna chiude la
finestra che c'é aria ma ciao dottor
martens i tuoi stivali di fiducia e la
romance così il fucile da cecchino
fantastico parà morto starà fingendo sul
national geova ricche perfetto ragazzi
abbiamo tutte le videocamere piazzate
non dovrebbero esserci nel più perfetto
ragazzi ma come ma no ma perché c'è un
cinghiale con una videocamera casa
famiglia la meta la ti prego non a caso
cori permuta o metterti st videocamera
in testa ma [ __ ] madre correva di
meno quando l'ho uccisa
messa
dai
[Musica]
messa succhia l'ho messo una videocamera
al porco quindi abbiamo 5 videocamere
installate tra cui un maiale chiudo
dentro ho fatto tutto sto casino e qua
dentro
ok perfetto ragazzi ci siamo si è scesa
la notte dopo la torcia famiglie
definisco statua ci ho passato la
giornata a piazza videocamera adesso che
ci sarà notte vediamo che cazzo
riusciamo a trovare ragazzi se troveremo
qualcosa che rimanga tra noi lo vini con
bastardo lo so che ci sei non servono a
[ __ ] informativo per scioglierlo
visto che anzi è così a questo è il mio
cinghiale bravo bello bravo vai alla
ricerca di quello stronzo perché non
posso piazzarlo comunque la telecamere
né o 5 che anche sul cinghiale di
potenza perché solo cinghiale morto a
caso come cazzo è possibile se io escono
trovo qua morto non ci credo ma che
cazzo la madonna che cosa era gamma si
sente seri sentite e non è normale
stanno ve lo dico io non è normale
ok se volete della carne andata conad
non fuori dalla mia roulotte
vedete che ragazzi pian piano troverò
qualcosa se non al limite prendono
camper e me ne vado a ibiza il visore
notturno sul cono che perfetto il visore
notturno una figata come farlo che
cos'era che è nata perché tra tutti i
ministeri che dovevo svelare proprio
quello del rake che bruttissimo cazzo
o che cazzo briga ho trovato cazzo via
via via via mia vita [ __ ] tua madre
che brutto che sai cos'è dov'è dove
cazzo è finito quel bastardo in un
proiettile super dove sei ragazze crono
agli alberi crollano questo successo
come di stato è stato orribile
dov'è fermi raiuno sto capendo più a
dove siamo perché ci siamo e come mai ci
siamo
ebbene successo che mi è spuntato il
rake dall'ansa che bene
bel gioco ha tentato anche di stuprargli
l'anno ma quello è un altro dettaglio
rega guarda milano guarda a milano ma
[ __ ] però era che si stronzo
proprio niente
infatti vedere un'altra volta fatti
vedere una macchina ma cosa
porca [ __ ] ragazzi
cos'è dove stiamo perché siamo cos'è sta
roba
la casa del rey non lo so dovevo
piazzarci la videocamera qua dentro lo
passi volta ci penso tre volte quanto mi
sono allontanato da mamma mia che
disastro fermiamo solo toccare tutti
indietro
ok ok ma aperti la prossima volta magari
non vedere non tu maledetto un cervo era
un cervo valle ma porca mignot
servirebbe tornare esploratrice ragazzi
dov'è il cervo goku sei tu hanno sparato
un cane ameal a voi che parte sembra
varie madre quando le dico che le
imprese 12 è che tipo arriva così eccolo
mamma lo presti l'ho preso che cazzo
correnti dove vai dove vai vieni qua ma
[ __ ] due proiettili da check 2 è
ancora vivo c'è una vita ben chiaro non
ammazzarlo del duo sparagli un cannone
impossibile è già un traguardo questo
quindi va bene così
please ritorno cioè l'ora di tornare a
ora niente tornano perfetto è finita la
nostra ragazzi siamo sopravvissuti tutti
e due ma io meritavo di più
sinceramente però che bella giornata di
merda che ciao ragazzi tutto a posto
guarda che me li mette davanti al camper
che lurido guarda zio che se volevo
darmi casa andavo da ikea non è qui che
cazzoni menti cosi un cassiere che
possono l'episodio perché dio santa
impossibile volete che lo continui solo
se volete fatemi sapere come mickey a
prenderlo per neanche beccare justin
bieber in italia è così facile fatemi
sapere ragazze classe il servizio è
piaciuto al trattamento mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook e come di video
tratta descrizione se questi discreta ci
vediamo al prossimo vita della ragazza